what was your general takeaway as you
watched the uh luna ust thing like what
was your general take in terms of
watching it in real time
yeah so i mean i'm i'm not gonna lie
like i wasn't too familiar with the luna
mechanics before they they added uh the
bitcoin reserves i thought it was an
interesting experiment um you know i i
called it like and people were attacking
me for calling it someone of a
ponzinomic stable coin like i didn't
know how it would end uh and then i saw
that peg drop you know from one to 98
cents and it was just limit down on 98
cents on binance with huge volume
and that was the point where i was
saying you know i had a kind of a thread
where i was just live tweeting my
thoughts and and what was happening at
the time
um and that's when i was like oh wow
there's
there's some there's some problems and
then the peg broke and luna was in in
collapse and at the point where you know
that the stable coin ust had a larger
market cap than luna um in my mind it
was clear that a bank run was happening
um and i joked about it going to zero i
didn't think it would legitimately go to
zero right away um but you know a lot of
smart people in the know um you know
capitalized and a lot of people
unfortunately lost a lot so it was a
tough experience but you know it was
definitely definitely something that was
quite memorable
all right so when you start to think
about uh that occurring uh obviously
bitcoin's price has uh dropped
significantly it was already down uh uh
pretty uh seriously but talk to me about
uh the entire situation of uh they
dumped 80 000 bitcoin or so and bitcoin
still you know 26 000 30 000 uh it's
held pretty strong like how do you feel
about watching them do that and kind of
the price action of bitcoins from that
yeah i mean really interesting i show
one of the i think the second chart we
have here today was showing just the
spot volumes right so
there's a couple kind of indicators or
things that we look at i mean more than
a couple but in terms of bitcoin bottoms
bitcoin tops
um we can see this sometimes in on chain
data but specifically when you're
looking at like spot exchanges and just
how much volume is or just how many
coins are changing hands right like if
you look at my four arrows here right
they're all pretty uh pretty significant
kind of uh moments are in the in the in
the price action in the bitcoin cycle um
you know doesn't mean it's necessarily a
macro bottom or a macro top but what we
can tell you is lots of coins changed
hands uh and it's pretty significant so
you know could bitcoin go lower yeah of
course and we're gonna you know walk
through some of the macro
uh just developments that have happened
um i've been talking about bonds and
credit and legacy market volatility for
you know for much of 2022 and that's
obviously still kind of the driver here
but in terms of kind of a capitulation
event um especially from a crypto native
standpoint um you saw bitcoin down big
but if you look at a lot of the kind of
the altcoins um which you know i don't
focus on too much i don't own uh but for
much of the 2020 you know 2021 bull run
uh the kind of the l1 smart contract
chain trade was was really big
luna solana avalanche and if you looked
at what happened directly after the
lunar crash all those all those kind of
markets were down 35 40 percent um and
you know as well as a lot of people who
are seemingly risk off and stable coins
got completely wiped out so there's
somewhat of a crypto contagion event and
bitcoin obviously took a hit but in
terms of everything else it it was it
was the crypto safe haven which is you
know somewhat crazy to think that
despite it being down like 10 12 percent